The best way to teach people how to think critically
Is by teaching them to write
I have written an article on the method of writing online
And I raised it in the name of Rubrik to write articles "rubric for essay writing"
"Students are asked whether they are in a location or not"
This article takes you through the steps of writing
Because what is happening now is that it is difficult to teach people how to write
Because that is time-consuming
The correction of the excellent article is very easy to put the mark right next to the full mark
But correct the bad article, my God wrong words, wrong phrases and wrong sentences are not properly arranged in the piece
The pieces are unconnected and the whole article has no meaning
So trying to tell the owner of the article errors is like you are telling him the whole article is wrong
This article was previously published under Q210586
But saying this will never help
But you have to find the few things they wrote correctly and then teach them to write it wrong
This is very expensive and expensive
So I have done in this article "Rubrik"
This article has been written by the production process rather than by the ratings and grades
The best thing you can do is teach people to write
Because there is no difference between them and thinking
And one of the things that kill me and do the universities
Is that no one tells students why they have to write something
But only say: You must do this duty. Why are you writing ? Because you need it to get a degree
This is wrong because you need to teach you to think
Thinking makes you active and effective in the world
Thinking makes you win in the debates you are having and which may be in favor of good things
If you can think, speak and write
You are definitely dead and nothing can stand in your way
That's why you learn to write
Writing is the most powerful weapon that can be supplied to one
I know a lot of people who were amazingly successful and watched them throughout my life
These people did not want to have any discussion against them
Because they will cut you to pieces
But not in a malicious way
But when they show their point while you are viewing your point
It is best to display your points regularly
Otherwise it will appear stupid and you really are
It will not reach anywhere
If you can formulate your argument in a coherent way then make an offer if you can then talk to people
Then if you can write a thesis, my God, people will give you money and opportunities
Will possess the ability to influence
This is why you are at university
You are in the English section is not it
Yes you teach people how to speak clearly
This is the most dangerous thing you can have
This is a catalyst if people know about it
When they say why you learn to write, you will say:
Here's your sword and here's your M16 and here's your bulletproof jacket
And you learn how to use them
But I have an unending mystery which is why I do not think of writing in this way automatically
This can lead you to madness when you try to find out why
It is as if there is a conspiracy to bring people into an education system to make them weaker
Thus reducing the number of competitors
Perhaps this is one way to think about why, when your students are idiots and idiots they will not challenge you